welcome back bombshell new development
in the wake of Michael Cohen's hearing
on Capitol Hill Republicans now asking
if he was coached by Democrats
beforehand sources say that Cohen met
with the staff of Democratic congressman
Adam Schiff four times over ten hours
leading up to his public testimony last
week Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis
defending the move saying it was quote
completely appropriate and he would have
done the same thing for Republicans had
they asked Dana I'm gonna start with you
because I know you're right
Bryan is writing this on my page and I
can't read what it says we had a pregame
for the people at home the reason I'm
going to Dana and Bryan first they were
getting into this before so they're both
fired up so I got fired up I don't
really care you think it's a huge deal
that Adam Schiff is shifty and there's a
problem so Dana do you Adam Schiff is
downplaying the saying that it's
completely right is it well I want to
hear her yell at Bryan you it brought
you yell back at what someone start and
then the other Lanny Davis is the lawyer
right he's a good one he's been through
this before and the committee is said
you're coming up here cuz you're gonna
have to talk to us because you lied to
us the last time you were here we want
to hear we want to see you up here we're
gonna go through this so we could walk
it through maybe that's an appropriate
except for that they offered it to the
Republicans as well and publicans didn't
want to do it okay fine that's fine
but the two biggest headlines that came
out of Michael Cohen's testimony the
number one thing that President Trump
wanted Michael Cohen said no evidence of
collusion number one so did the
Democrats coach him to say that and the
second headline was president Trump did
not directly tell me to lie okay so
those are the two things that were the
president could possibly in trouble for
Michael Cohen sides with the president
on those two things so if the Democrats
were trying to coach him they didn't do
a very good job so Brian's raising his
gun so Bryan ding-ding-ding you're next
okay first off it'll bothers me at the
deception when he asked he originally
Adam Schiff says who was just talking
about logistics and he was worried about
his security that's not true they met
five times for 12 hours my goodness and
you told me somebody didn't know I did
not know Republicans were invited to
come to New York and meet with him so
that's well they were so they little
bits
that it was at this length they had no
idea that's why Turner wrote that letter
saying did you actually rehearse this
was this a rehearsal some of these q and
A's that got on the record number two is
the Benghazi hearings all the
controversy with them in Ghazi hearings
there was one time in which a Democrat
was not invited to a one-on-one session
with the key witness because a
whistleblower wasn't too secure with
what he was going to say that it
wouldn't have leaked out to the media
and Elijah Cummings going crazy so just
do it the same way there's no legal
reason to bring Republicans in but it's
the right thing to do traditionally and
it did come out they said that he
changed they said the Trump lawyers
changed his remarks and they didn't that
turned out to be wrong they didn't
change theirs marks because they found
his original the Moscow Tower talk
stopped in January that's exactly the
Cohen hearings at the end of the day did
that help or hurt President Trump and I
would argue that it absolutely helped
him well into that point Greg I want to
get you in on this please do so the
point that Dana just made does it help
wasn't listening
like a crazy show in the morning you
don't even know their wallet in the
morning you're sleeping till noon
does that help order in the court does
it help anyone to embrace Michael Cohen
because I see your point about Adam
what's his shift being shifty I don't
think people keep saying he's like he's
like Joe McCarthy right he's on this
witch hunt that's what the Republicans
compared he's more in my opinion like
Charlie McCarthy and that he's a doll on
strings and the strings are pulled by an
activist media he's doing all of this
because he's being rewarded with the
spotlight he and he's so wooden and
stiff he makes John Kerry look like a
gummy worm but he's like he is in
control of the media and as long as the
media is chasing this he'll keep chasing
them well I gotta say I got to introduce
you to Devon newness because if you guys
who was playing racquet media and
absolutely a stooge for president Trump
guess what that was Devon unas when he
was in charge of house Intel so I mean I
don't and let me know and I think that
when you stop and review the
idea that this is a witness who had lied
to them in 17 to the Congress the idea
that they would say well we want to
review what you're gonna talk about we
want to know what you have knowledge of
so that we can prepare going over things
like catch and kill stories with the
National Enquirer exactly what was David
Axelrod put out a tweet in response to
the House Judiciary Committee's sweeping
document request from 81 people saying
that this plays in to president Trump's
witch-hunt narrative doesn't it no it
plays into a media narrative the tries
to set because the Congress has a
legitimate oversight but all these
people I'm sorry the David Axelrod
bought into this distortion because you
want the Congress to ascertain the facts
before bringing any charges or going
after impeachment they aren't doing that
isn't it they're gathering facts that's
their legitimate role but isn't it
redundant though when Muller has already
been doing this investigation since 2000
oh it's nice you don't even know what's
in the Muller report so I mean let's
assume that Muller comes up with nothing